hey you do parties
we're here at Gamescom 2018 time now
I've just seen Devil May Cry 5 Sam
you're the devil make our expert of the
two of us what you think of it I like
that a lot I want to start like by
upfront saying not a huge fan of the
passive aggressive like digs at DMC
Devil May Cry that it's having I just
like built into the market as well Devil
May Cry is back it's like I definitely
cried the last one was great I don't
know what you're doing having said that
he is very much evoking the nostalgia
for all the games to the point where
when the demo starts and you press star
and in cycle up and down they've used
the same sound effects from the original
Devil May Cry so like everyone as soon
as you start playing you realize that
this is classic they'll make cry sound
and feel having said that it kind of
plays in a quite modern way they're
taking they've done some modernization
to to the world mechanics one of the
first thing you notice is the cameras
really pulled in close it's very close
very very it feels almost like Resident
Evil style over the shoulder Gears of
War style camera and it's also like a
free moving camera as well which is a
commonplace in action games now but it
makes it feel quite different in a lot
of ways like people are used to having
like very fixed perspective in classical
McRae games this gives it a little more
like openness it feels more and even
though it's really tight in and in terms
of how it actually plays it's very much
in line with how people expect the
classic double May Cry Luke to work like
it's swords guns and then an extra
ability now big electric fist big
electric fist and that's like prosthetic
arm seem to be the thing honestly like
between this insecure Oh everyone's
rocking a prosthetic on these days so he
plays Nero he's back and
it's kind of like prosthetic arm works
in a similar way to it the way he did in
Devil May Cry 4 where he'd like grab
people from afar yeah so like and you
use that in the flow of combat to kind
of build chains together so you knock
someone into the air you launch yourself
up with them do it for you sword swipes
knock him away and then use your grab to
pull them back or pull an enemy in the
interesting thing is like you can charge
the arm and then do a charge it to the
point where it explodes after you use it
so then he's effectively one working
with one arm for a while and that's
really really intricate
other arms in the environment yeah one
is like a push one had like electricity
to it yeah and there's moments that you
say that if you get grabbed by an enemy
you can throw your arm at them to like
create a gap and escape as well so it's
like you you have this risk to reward or
kind of like you make a sacrifice if you
want to do a lot of damage but then it
means that you don't have this ability
for a little longer which is a really
interesting way to come at combat
scenarios because generally like you go
into every combat scenario in most
action games with the tall set you have
at the time and that doesn't change this
is kind of like what if we took this one
thing away from you for a little bit and
it kind of makes you rethink how you
need to approach each combat scenario so
that's the pro se con is super super
important you still have your guns as
well like in this I had like a shotgun
style thing which was like quite slow
but does a lot of damage and it would
between that the sword and the arm which
has its own ability on its own like
there was one which was like an
electrical yeah it was like re different
ones or something yeah so like you do
load like a short-range explosion of
electricity and there was the other one
like you said where you press it and it
kind of like the launches you upwards
and forward that was really cool because
then you could like knock enemies up
into the air and then like chase them
within the area's pledged not come down
and they're like push yourself towards
them and like grab them as well it's
really really like satisfying to go from
ground to air and it also feels like
really really like satisfying to hit
people with it that's the one things
that's really
when you like swipe your sword it needs
to feel like you're cutting through
something and it does do that
well I've sent to you I haven't played a
definite cry really since I think three
maybe even two and so I was kind of
worried that I'd go into this game being
a bit overwhelmed and at first there's
quite a lot to think about like the
goodies the new mechanic like juggling
enemies that the roller mechanic which
I'm not a fan of but you say it's very
good classic Devil May Cry yeah but I
found myself after five minutes just
doing some really cool [ __ ] yeah and
that's that's all I wanted from that
experience and that's what a lot of
people want from a micro game it doesn't
like the rolling thing that you said is
like the the what's interesting is like
what's changed in that genre since is
like platinum games has redefined how
you play those games like you have one
button mechanics - yeah create that
dodge like bayonet is which time you
press a button she dodges it it's quite
liberal and everything slows down this
is very much the opposite way if you
want to dodge something you need to lock
on aim and then roll its classic there
when we cry and although like that feels
familiar I don't know how people are
gonna I think it's very much aimed at
the hardcore players like it doesn't
seem like I needed it that much with the
whole like grappling hook mechanic the
only thing anyway but so there a demo
ended with a large boss that was doing
like really sweeping movements and I
found like in that scenario the
grappling using Oh being overly reliant
on the grapple could be tricky because
you pull yourself in and because he had
this really sweeping motion with his arm
he could knock you back and you quickly
lose that and lose health so I relied on
the role a lot more see I didn't use for
that if I didn't use the role much at
all I was using the grappling hook and
the push to get behind him yeah slashing
his back and I I pretty much didn't
touch the ground but then he would he
would use an ability that like sucked me
into his chest and then fires you are
yeah so you sure he was able to
encounter both like strategies of play
yeah so when I was doing that because of
the large rate like range and how much
is that fire attack for example covered
here's the screen it felt again like
very much the old devil may cry way
you'd non-stop roll to get out of the
way of things like that was almost like
the invincibility frames that other role
would keep you safe for a little while
so there's times when I was playing
old-school style where I'm just
constantly rolling out in the way of
things just to get some breathing room
which is something that doesn't happen
in action games now now it's like you
turn the tables instead of being on the
defensive so it kind of felt good to
have that back and forth between a
classic and a modern feeling game and
the other things that are kind of very
very traditional Devil May Cry is the
style of it and the ridiculous
ludicrous like setups there's a bit way
he's like Nero standing there and a
ambulance falls on him and it's like the
ambulance is positioned perfectly so
that the door the ER the inside of a
side door like goes he lands in between
that and then it like spins over and it
hits a wall and then he comes out and
you're like oh it's so over-the-top
style yeah almost to the point of like
parody yeah yeah it's the only game that
it would work in its devilment right
yeah it's it's it's very much what
people want from it and it's one of the
reasons that people are less interested
they don't have as kind things to say
about DMC doesn't like right I think it
did it better like it balanced that
stuff because by the time Devil May Cry
4 came out it was full-on cheesy you had
Dante with a rose in his mouth like
dancing around different like action
sequences and I was not a huge fan of
that stuff now it feels like a little
more balanced like Nero is he's less
angsty now it's like they transplanted
Dante's personality on to Nero's looks
and that's the character that you get
now like we know that Dante is in the
game to what capacity is unclear yet he
seems like he's on he might be like
gruff demon hunter back from retirement
or he could be even the villain I'd love
to see my villain but yeah from what I
played so far and very much excited
about playing what I love to do my cry
series like they say it's like they're
saying like going double me cry it is
back as for it is back is a classic
Devil May Cry game and I think a lot of
fans are gonna respond to that really
really well but if you want to see the
sick [ __ ] gameplay that we actually
played we're gonna have that up on site
and on YouTube as well so make sure you
guys check that out for everything else
Devil May Cry 5 stay tuned to games Bob
the grapple hooked was
let's rock baby ha as what
[Music]